the feminists become being anti-men
shoes
study of human behavior red bullies
anti-womeness because even if
he's the comments left by red pill men
it can never be a rational debate it
will never be like I disagree with this
it's like tell her where's her makeup
from where's her and it's like so angry
where you can't have rational
conversations with red pill man you I'll
watch these comments today
that sounds like a you problem because I
have rational conversations
that's why our conversations with red
pill men and if they were anti-missile
never stop interrupting me stop
interrupting me and if they were
anti-misogynistic then I would have an
issue but they're not but you you say
that you speak their language very few
people say po where's your ring very few
men were so well
wrong wrong I was just on an interview
yeah I was grilled for two hours
straight by a freaking blue pill betta
set I'm talking about red pills
listen listen listen to me what I'm
saying I've had conversations with red
pill guy anti-marriage guy anti this
this this this guy never had an issue
the only issue I've ever had and and got
grilled on this that stuff was by blue
pill dude exactly what my point is
Redfield men will never come for you
because you speak their language but if
you try and tell them rational debates
and give them logical answers that
aren't regurgitated Kevin Samuel videos
or anything they'll come for you they
really will and that's right it's not
constructive that's not true because
when I started I wasn't red pill
I have two years I have I have two years
worth of videos the first time I watched
canvas Samuels I did not say nice things
about I was not a fan and I never had
issues with misogyny I never had issues
with like women haters I just said the
only thing they debate is ideas I mean I
mean they might troll you a little bit
if anything you won't experience it
because you don't speak no and opposite
language you're not listening to what
I'm saying when I started on YouTube
I did not agree with everything I had
many
as I said twenty thousand twenty
thousand and now you're on I have more
now what's your point but you keep
moving the goal because you said you
speak their language I said when I
didn't speak their language I had no
issue so it's a you problem because even
even when I when I did not speak their
language I had no issues well I can
speak from my experience when I say any
video that agrees with men like if I say
women shouldn't dress like this or
feminism is this I'll get the men raving
reposting moment you call them out and
say no no also men need to do this just
to create a rational balance dialogue
they turn into the male equivalent of
feminists where they lose all their
rationality and become emotional and
they'll start making personal remarks
the exact same thing they accuse women
of doing they go to being personal when
they don't have a lot of logical
argument does the comment section roast
yes yeah but it doesn't bother me that
they Rose me they can say whatever they
want but the reality is it only happens
when I don't talk their language and
they display the same emotional
dysregulation as a feminist they claim
to hate the feminists that say I hate
women all men are trash the red pill men
when you don't speak their language it
displayed the exact level of femininity
irrationality and personal remarks that
we are always told that women do I mean
I just think it's silly to go on the
internet and not expect to give bad
comments so so on both sides yeah on
both sides so it's like did you get hate
comments does that does that mean the
whole red pill movement when I've when I
I'm the one who knows all of the people
that lead the space I'm the one who's
met them you're basing your experience
off of the comment section no I'm basing
it off the red pill community that I see
and what I find okay have you met any of
them in person other than me
so I'm saying with the red pill men that
you that you're talking about have you
met any yeah I've met any any any
content creators no content creators
I've been in contact with a few but
online and stuff but not in person
because they're usually American okay so
so you haven't even dealt with them and
you're making an assumption about them
but I can make an assumption based on
like you haven't dealt with feminists or
whales or [ __ ] that but you can make an
assumption because they come for you
right I can make an assumption based on
the ones I've talked to in real life
where I was attacked but I've never I've
never communicated with feminists but
I've had feminists contact my workplace
and then try and get me fired I've had
feminists that have come from my parents
photo phone numbers and address so I can
make an assumption on them even though I
haven't met them in real time because I
live I've never met a feminist no I'm a
feminist yeah you met me and yeah but I
could still make assumptions on the
extremities of both red pill and
feminism because I experienced both of
them in real life but I've had my job
contacted I've had my boss call me in
and say this we've been sent this I've
had feminist posts repost my videos it's
like a crazy person rather than like a
person that has but the extremities on
each end are as bad as each other it's
as bad as each other red pill men are
the male equivalent of feminists when
they go to that extreme because what
happens with both of them is that they
forget to incorporate their own
experiences and they just have this
mindset of hate and anger and they've
not even listening to the argument they
just want to show so you're a woman or
don't ask a woman what a man needs don't
ask a woman about outfit no no what
speak rationally have a rational
discourse I mean the the point they're
making about don't ask a woman like what
you're talking about dating advice
General like you can't ask a woman when
the alpha is can't ask what high
evaluate well you can't ask a woman is
what what are you talking about you can
ask humans what humans do yeah I mean
you can ask but
usually they talk about dating advice
like don't take dating advice from women
it's like are you asking the fishermen
that's usually what they're talking
about but then wouldn't that also apply
then don't ask men for men advice
because you don't ask the fish like when
that be don't ask men for men well see
now because men have had to listen to
what women have to say for years women
don't have to listen to what men have to
say that's why it's so triggering a lot
of times when I say things on this
podcast like men know what we want
because they've had to listen to us for
the last 20 30 years
um
but okay I'll be honest um can we Define
like red pill and blue pill because I
mean I'm just thinking like ibuprofen
and Viagra I have no idea
it sounds like
um
people that do you know do you remember
menism it sounds like it's that versus
feminism is it is that right is that is
that no I mean red pill is apraxiology
it's a study of human behavior that's
what it is okay but what is it in real
world because feminism is equal rights
but really in the real world feminism
how are the masses perceived yeah right
now perhaps in real time
what do you mean in real life that's all
I'm saying is this based off the matrix
it's so [ __ ] everybody loves it I
haven't seen The Matrix I haven't
haven't watched Game of Thrones
but how does the study of like human
behavior correlate to to the like this
topic as in like how does it apply to
dating and advice and all of that what's
the dynamic there
how does it reply to date well so like
gosh there's so much that goes into it
but it's just like women so for example
they study women like and why women do
the things they do so like women look
for different things at different ages
so like for example women one thing they
talk about is a woman's sexual market
value so like when she's at her highest
and what she would look for when she's
the most attractive to men so for
example if
women in their early 20s tend to look
for looks well women in their late 20s
to 30s tend to look for security and
that so they would say like these are
the examples and yeah
what makes some of them so triggered
where they just spew out hate and to any
woman that has an opinion I don't know
any content creators that do that um I
can't help the comment section so I
think a lot of people like I
is like fresh and Fit I would say Marlon
I would say is very angry
yeah no I don't I don't think so
actually
um I mean he just people don't like his
tone and I think women have an issue
with his tone but no I I don't think he
hates women by any means does he come
across as somebody who has successful
relationships with women and can have a
marriage and a stable relationship with
women yeah I think he could I don't
think he comes across it yeah I mean I
would disagree I mean I don't think they
hate women
um no I don't think that you don't think
he insults the uh like the women's
mindset in general or anything like that
I don't personally look at something I
have a specific example like the time he
speaks to women in general how not how
he speaks what he says so he might say
something like um well you're 20 once a
woman's more than 25 she's got no value
and if you haven't got a ring you have a
good opinion women can't Define high
value women can't Define Alpha men women
don't have uh can't solve any of men's
problems
let me start with the 20th okay because
you're giving me a bunch so what was the
first one you said 20 women over 25 yeah
they have no value yeah I mean I don't
think that's misogynistic but no every
age has a cut off so every guy is like
every guy has your mom has no value
my Mom has nobody yeah I've talked to my
mom about this in the sexual Marketplace
nah good luck my mom on the dating scene
you're telling me my mom like I love I
love you Mom I love you he's talking
about not it's not not personal words
it's sexual market value so I mean most
guys will date a girl for 25 like she
looks good true true so maybe maybe he's
pickier he prefer girls under 25 the
point is women under over the age of 25
typically we've had our heart broke
Hearts broken and men have to deal with
that so it's easier to get with a
younger girl who has it hasn't had drama
okay do you want do you want to grow
with more trauma or less trauma guy well
I didn't ask you then more trauma or
less trauma less trauma more trauma or
less trauma
okay so so so this is this is as women
we listen and say I understand that
instead of trying to argue and tell you
them what they want yeah and I'm not
going to be offended is my mom gonna do
well on The Dating Market with 10 kids I
don't want to dating my of course no but
I don't think no I didn't mean it in
sexual I meant in general as a value as
a person but uh I can speak for somebody
when I was 21 and then going to 25. I
genuinely think I I did more reflection
and became less traumatized as I was 10
25. I personally felt like I was far I
was so volatile at 21. I was so
impulsive at 21 as I became old I became
less of a burden to a man but we're not
talking about you we're talking about in
general humans yeah we're more emotional
and volatile I'm saying like in general
we're not like he doesn't know your
specific story so so if if we're talking
to the men and the men like Andrew Tate
said something similar or women over the
age of 2019 and they're and they're
saying 19. he gave the age of 19. and he
and if they're saying we prefer the
women younger yeah like why are we to
tell them what they want no no you I
think it should be with a younger woman
I really do think younger is more
beautiful and especially when it comes
to having kids but it's also saying
things like oh women can't Define what
makes them mad women have no definition
of what makes an album a biological
terms
no the point they're making though is
that like for a man to be Alpha to be
high value he asked to be selected by
other men first like other men have to
respect him first before the women can
come in and so that that's that's what
they're talking about someone
disqualified for realizing or not being
able to make because you can look at a
monkey and decide which one's Alpha
you'd have to be other other men have
other high-value men have to recognize
him as a part of the group so so I mean
we're kind of interchanging high value
in Alpha but but when it comes to high
value men that's what they're talking
about yeah it's the other high value the
other no because of the other high value
men have to recognize him as part of the
group and can a low value man realize a
high value man I think most men when
they walk into a room they can they can
just naturally tell
it's definitely a hierarchy and women
can tell as well they call us a cap yeah
we can tell when something yeah you
think so
why do you think women and historically
like the the fathers have been involved
women suck at picking men we do I'm
looking I'm as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible